Think back.
Where were you in May of 2020?
Like many other educators,
I was preparing to close out
the most unique school year
in my time as a teacher,
after spending the past couple of months
trying to figure out how to teach online
from my kitchen table
while also navigating
the uncertainty and trauma
of a global health pandemic.
And then on May 25, 2020,
George Floyd was murdered
in police custody in Minneapolis.
In the wake of this tragedy
and the days of civil
unrest that followed,
my colleagues and I realized
we couldn't just keep showing up
to our virtual classes
to teach math and science
and reading and writing
as if everything was fine.
And so we gathered on Zoom one morning
to face an urgent question:
What do we say to the kids?
Since that day,
I've started reflecting
on more moments like this.
Growing up in the '80s and '90s,
I remember my parents telling me
about two specific dates
where they remember
exactly where they were
and exactly what they were doing.
These were the dates
that president John F. Kennedy
and Dr. Martin Luther King, Jr.
were assassinated.
A generation later,
these memorable events for me
were the Columbine school shooting
and September 11, 2001.
The more I reflected on these
"where were you when" moments,
both as a teacher
and then later as a social
and emotional learning specialist,
I realized that they share
distinct characteristics.
They're collectively experienced.
They're disruptive to daily life
and often they cause a shift in beliefs,
behaviors or even policies.
And today's young people,
perhaps due to globalization
or social media,
may be faced with even more of them.
And so educators like me, I assumed,
must be faced with even more of these
"What do we say to the kids?" moments too.
So I've actually done
quite a bit of study of this question
and I'm going to tell you
what we say to the kids.
And not just for educators,
but for parents and caregivers
and anyone who interacts with
or supports young people.
In my doctoral research,
I came to call these moments
consciousness-shifting current events,
which are occurrences that have
a profound collective impact
on the community, state or nation
where they take place
and usually cause a change in awareness,
attitude or behavior
among those impacted by it.
I'm going to share the insights
from my research with you today,
but I have to first offer a disclaimer
that, since it’s not yet published --
hope to do that this spring --
I am going to focus
on general broad conclusions
and leave out any personal details
that could be used
to identify my participants.
And so with that in mind,
the first broad conclusion
I want to share with you
is that silence is not an option.
The educators I spoke to told me
that it was a moral imperative
to address these events with students.
If it wasn't clear before,
the era of COVID-19 has made it clear now
that education is an essential industry.
And as front line workers,
educators are tasked
with more than teaching.
They're responsible
for supporting the physical
and emotional well-being of students
amidst a wide variety of social crises
and collective traumas:
natural disasters,
civil unrest,
racial injustice,
community violence,
and of course, a global pandemic.
All of the educators in my study
expressed some degree of self-doubt
and a lack of confidence
addressing these topics with students.
Yet, in the stories they shared
and the strategies that they shared
with one another,
I discovered that actually most educators
actually do have an implicit understanding
of what needs to happen in those moments
to get students back
to a place of learning.
And so today I'm going to share
with you the three key moves
that I saw educators making,
the steps they took
to facilitate community healing
in their schools and classrooms.
First, they sought to restore
a sense of safety.
Now here's what this looks like.
In one classroom,
it meant facilitating breathing
and mindfulness exercises
to help students self-regulate,
to soothe the fight-or-flight
regions of their brain
that had been activated
after a tornado swept through their region
and destroyed a nearby town.
Another educator told me about a student
who was a refugee from a country
in political upheaval
and on the day of the US
capitol insurrection,
this student was particularly
distraught and inconsolable
in comparison to her peers
because her belief that the turmoil
she had left behind in her home country
could not and would not happen here
had been shattered.
She was worried
that her parents were unsafe
and she wasn't going to be
reunited with them
at the end of a school day.
So the teacher reassured this student
that she and her family
were not in any physical danger.
And then took out a map
of the United States
to demonstrate that although,
yes, what was happening in DC
was in the same country,
it was nearly 3,000 miles away.
By focusing on safety and security,
these educators prioritize what Maslow
tells us are our basic human needs.
The lesson I learned here
is that when bad things happen,
we don't jump right to analyzing
the root causes that got us here.
We don't try to figure out who's to blame
or even how to fix it yet.
We simply try to hold it together
and make sure our people are protected.
But of course we don't
and we can't stop there.
After restoring physical
or psychological safety,
educators engage in heart work.
That is, they tend to emotions,
both their own
and those of their students.
This often involves with educators
modeling their own vulnerability,
admitting they're scared or uncertain
or don't have all the answers
and feel anxious about that.
It also involves creating space
for students to do the same.
Many of the educators in my study
talked about using talking circles
as a way for students to process
what they're going through
without judgment.
One told me about using
a virtual talking circle
for both adults and young people
to navigate feelings of grief and loss
and fear associated with coronavirus.
A theater arts teacher shared with me
how she helped students process
the death of a classmate.
Realizing that students didn't feel
comfortable talking openly,
she led them in a silent activity
to create artistic representations
of their thoughts and emotions.
Now heart work can be hard work,
but here's why it matters.
When we navigate our emotions,
it moves us from that survival
part of our brain
to a more emotionally regulated state.
And do you know what else is possible
when we're operating
from that calmer state?
Connection.
Love.
Belonging. Community.
So it's by reinforcing
and strengthening the relationships
that we have with one another
that we get through the hard times.
It's how we develop positive coping
strategies and ultimately resilience.
And this connection,
this sense of
“we’re all in this together,”
is what cultivates hope
and leads us to the final step:
empowering action.
Now we've seen this many times
in various social movements
but powerful and inspiring action
is happening on smaller scales
and without social media coverage
in classrooms and schools all over.
In the days after 9/11,
a teacher took a page
from the “Mister Rogers’ Playbook”
by looking for and honoring the helpers.
The teacher talked about firefighters
and first responders.
Faith leaders from a variety of religions.
Everyday people providing food, shelter
and support to their neighbors.
The day after the 2016 presidential
election of Donald Trump,
students whose families
were primarily undocumented
expressed rage and terror,
fearing that their families
and they would soon be deported.
Recognizing their sense
of helplessness and hopelessness,
their teacher went to work
creating opportunities for students
to learn about how to get involved
in political advocacy and activism.
And when community violence
took away students' outdoor recess
because it was deemed too unsafe,
they started a podcast.
And they used that platform
to raise awareness,
build support among community leaders
and plan a peace march.
What's key here is that we don't let
ourselves or our people
get stuck in the yuck.
Rather than dwelling
in despair, we mobilize.
We reject helplessness
and deficit-based thinking
and harness our individual
and community assets
to advocate and agitate for change.
Ginwright calls this
healing-centered engagement
and tells us that this approach
to addressing trauma
requires a different question
that moves beyond
"what happened to you,"
to "what's right with you."
And it looks at those affected by trauma
as agents in the creation
of their own well-being.
The idea here is that it's by finding
what's right with all of us,
our collective strengths,
that we can begin to heal and transform
ourselves and our communities.
And so I return once more to the question,
“what do we say to the kids?”
We say to the kids
that it's okay to feel
scared and vulnerable.
We say to the kids
that our safety was taken from us,
but we will together
create safety once again.
We say to the kids that it's time
to start the heart work
and we will show them how to do it.
We tell them to keep feeling
because our feelings
are what makes us human
and what will help heal us.
And finally, we say to the kids
that we must rebuild
together through action.
Each and every one of us.
Today, I hope you will feel empowered,
I hope we will all feel empowered,
to support our communities, our educators
and our young people in healing.
And so the next time
a consciousness-shifting event happens,
we'll not only know what to say,
we'll know what to do,
and we'll know how to be.
Thank you.
(Applause)